the best way to kill someone is you go
on a walk with them push them off a
cliff
you're like oh they they fell off the
cliff they tripped
[Music]
bonjour and welcome to episode 2 of she
doesn't read the news with me
chris turner and me alice win
alice win my wife hey wife i still don't
read the news
you still don't really haven't started
last week's episode
it would be a bit of a dick move if i
was like actually now i've decided
i'd like to start reading the news chris
that's it's a good way it would be a way
to get out of the podcast
it would just be five minutes i'd be
like sir big news stories this week this
happened yeah i know
thanks for tuning in guys bye-bye before
we barrel on i'm dressed as a frenchman
i wasn't going to remark on it thank you
uh or you
as you say je nero marquez how would you
say that in french
so we we've been filming my new video
which is
a french song i am dressed in the words
of your mother
like an english person's idea of a
frenchman
chris it turns out actually has quite a
lot of xenophilic
no xenophilic no i like no no but you
answered you are xenophobic you have a
lot of xenophobia towards france
uh it's sort of typical of the
englishman yeah i think no more than the
average english well
i think i think the point is that french
people don't hate england
nearly as much or as often as english
people hate france i think that's in
in many rivalries i just think the
french
things to think about northerners you
know [ __ ] on london
but london as i don't think think about
the north that much at all yes but think
about where the power lies
so the implication is that the person
who doesn't care about the rivalry
always has more power than the person
who does care
so england is lower status in the france
england rivalry
oh that's not very nice sorry still they
haven't got any vaccines and we do
news story that you don't know about
because you haven't read the news this
is the part where we discuss our week
now
we should address um that we've done an
episode already
we put it up yes um we don't look at
comments on it
but your brother sent them through to
the family whatsapp and uh people people
seem to
enjoy it my brother might have only sent
like the single nice comments oh okay
that's true
well i had some nice comments uh some
people sent through the instagram mainly
concerning
how you were going to overshadow me and
uh take the limelight and blow me away
which is
my plan begins yeah exactly push me off
that that metaphorical cliff and then
the real cliff
which is the best way to kill someone no
i absolutely said the best way to kill
someone is
you go on a walk with them push them off
a cliff you're like oh they
they fell off the cliff they tripped
yeah as long as no one
sees you push them so we both agree
that we should never go on walks near
cliffs because the temptation will be
too great it's like that feeling you
have when you're on a bridge and you're
like
i want to throw my phone off the bridge
or whenever i go through airport
security and i think of all the ways i
could sneak bombs onto the plane
yeah do you remember the time we took
colonel within's our cat for the
uninitiated
um it sounds like it's a cult yeah if
you watch my videos you have to love my
cat
we took him through chris's agent had to
have a chat with him
about how much chris put pictures of his
cat on his instagram
and his agent was like no one likes it
it makes you look deeply uncool
you need to stop and so chris now puts
up like
way fewer cat pictures than he used to
but uh every time you put up a cat
picture you still lose like tons of
followers
i think it's more a case of they were
like you whittled down to the yeah
yeah it's you know i'm refining my
audience
colonel within is a huge part of my life
and if you're not okay with that
then you can unfollow i don't mind we
were taking colonel weddings through
airport security
and that guy was like oh i'll need to
take that cat
out of the bag to examine it like what
and so he like takes the cat to a
separate room
he just wanted to talk he just wanted to
touch the cat he was like look to be
fair with you i just want to strut that
cat that looks like a fluffy fool it's
like i have to go and
be alone with this cat for a minute yeah
it's probably just like sobbed into his
fur
yeah which you know was his mistake
because we had stuffed a ton of heroin
off colonel
well exactly but he didn't catch it
that's how we smuggle well if we've been
put his mummy would it there would be
cat [ __ ]
oh gross ah it's a great joke it's a
great job
um we've we so what we've done stuff
this week we've watched some films we
watched
eyes wide shut boring yeah real bad
isn't it yeah
come at me with all your your opinions
people did so i put up i put up um
like instagram reviews of the films i
watch
um and i truly think it's like my
it's the true peak of my artistic
prowess is these these reviews
and uh people hated my review of eyes
white shark they had
they had opinions almost as much as when
you slagged off casablanca
boring film it's the engine of the film
doesn't work
i disagree with you relationship i think
it's because alice thinks that the
romance
is flawed and that's the driving engine
which it is
whereas i i didn't really care about
that i'm like yeah he's handsome she's
fit of course they want to be together
it doesn't make any sense they don't
have anything to talk about
why would they like why is there such a
anyway this was the past where
women were just supposed to sit there
because there's plenty of films in the
past that have great relationships and
catholic language isn't one of them
the other stuff like the kind of setting
of
a lot of the film is good but it's got
this central flaw that i think makes it
mm-hmm
i am going to get a lot of hate you are
yeah really the only bad thing about
casablanca is nazis and you you know
uh that was an awful what was even that
about um you are gonna get you are going
to get a lot of
hate but eyes white shirt is boring um
we watched phantom thread
that's good it's not boring isn't it you
enjoyed that i think you were surprised
that i
because it's a film about a 1950s
dressmaker and you previously have never
liked daniel day-lewis
mainly because he's been in lincoln
which again which i think
lasted i mean i i feel like it lasted
the entire year i was 21. i started to
watch it and it just felt like then
like my life just got shorter when
lincoln got shot
you cheered finally in phantom thread
there is a a part where he talks about
how you can sew
secrets into the dress and he sews a
little slip into the wedding dress that
says never cursed
and it reminded me and i have a very
poor memory for my life events
so it was quite nice to get this little
zing back to the time i worked in my
secondary schools in my high school's
lost property department
used to have to volunteer at least once
a month i think for
every boy had to do something in the
school to kind of give back
and so i did lost property because it
was fun like you just hung out with
another person and just chatted and no
one ever came to get stuff
and i found a blazer so one of our
school jackets for our school uniform
and as i thought there was something in
the pocket so i reached in there was
nothing in the pocket i thought it might
be like a
calculator but i couldn't figure out how
to get it until i realized it was
stitched into the lining
of the coat and so i was like i need to
figure out what this is so i just kind
of like unstitched it
and pulled out what we would call a
stanley knife what i think americans
would call
a craft knife and someone had stitched
a knife into their jacket into their
jacket lining
not quick access but like yeah i'm
smuggling this into school
i took that in my stride i was like oh
yeah someone's taking a knife to school
huh but they probably weren't aiming to
like mass
knife people no i think they probably
just had the knife because they're like
you know
maybe they were being bullied or
something yeah so they were like i'll
knife the next person
it's a good strategy people always say
like oh stand up t-bully punch him
knife knife yeah do not knife bullies or
do not condone it
no i feel like my feelings on casablanca
yeah just to loot back just to expand on
this
obviously it's a good film i'm not
saying it's not a good film
but i just feel as if there's you're not
allowed to make any criticism of it
because it's supposed to be the single
best film of all time
in the world often ranks that high and
the fact is
that that they don't have anything in
common like there's literally a scene
where they're like hanging out in paris
and then
like he asks her a question about her
life and she goes no questions
try and have a conversation with someone
where you never
ask them any questions and never answer
any questions and see how quickly
you you form a like lasting and
successful romance because
i'm telling you that's not a healthy
relationship
just more and more hate hate tweets are
going to be coming in
the start of our week was very nice we
had a burns night celebration we did
celebrate burns great point rabbit bones
chris did that accent for about
24 hours that was great it was lovely i
made some shortbread uh i made some
mints and no tatties which are potatoes
because we didn't have any potatoes
your mother doesn't like potatoes yeah
she does there's never potatoes in this
house
i thought that they were like the food
the staple food
it's not here interesting remarks from
chris turner
hey hey hot button topics and potato
wraps so
so chris read some very very uh bawdy
robbie burns poems oh are you gonna do
something i do i have it this poem
we have a book of burns poetry and i my
eye caught upon one
called nine inch will please a lady
and he's not talking about trent
reznor's band guys
um i'll just read a couple of things uh
come read me dame come tell me dame my
dame come tell me truly
what length of grace when wheel cadheem
will see her a woman julie
so that to translate this uh old scotch
is uh come and tell me lady and be
honest what length
and girth when your man's there
will make you happy um now
the second verse and this is i i said
the c word to your mother
you did yeah i'm not saying what that
word is because youtube has a real
problem
yeah if you put the c word in your video
it nerfs it it is not happy
i think that's sexist i think that is
very sexist you know i think the people
who are on youtube are all
a massive bunch of c words uh the second
verse i had to say this and your mother
was very
okay wait i had to say that i had to say
i was being
forced to read robbie burns but for a
country
like mine in sooth were nasa gentle
we tacked a thumb bread to the nine and
that's a saucy pintle
so i think that means for my rural
vagina
uh it's not you know it doesn't need to
be treated
gently you can you know take two thumbs
breath
so a penis of two thumbs width uh
to the nine length and that's a sansi
pintle i believe pintle means penis
and sansi means good saucy sure maybe
yeah saucy as well
um and then it does have the advice that
the
immortal uh advice and i've just seen
here this work was published before
january
first 1926 and therefore is in the
public domain so that's good you can you
can't sue me robbie burns for reading
your poetry
and the final verse is great but where i
feed the lathan dupe and merit naked
raven it's not the length it gives me
lou but it's the double driving it's not
the length it's not the it's the motion
of the ocean that's what they're saying
come nid me time come not me time come
nidge me or the navel come
lace and lug your battering realm and
thrash them at make evil
you're battering around they're great so
that's that's uh
i do really love very old sexy
literature like one of my favorite books
uh
i read in university was um memoirs of a
woman of pleasure
by john cleveland cleveland and
basically it's about this girls from the
1740s and
she's just like a sweet innocent girl
from the countryside who comes to the
big city to make her fortune
uh where she is snapped up immediately
by a whorehouse
um and she has her sexual awakening with
a fellow girl in the whole house called
phoebe
and then basically the rest of the book
is just this like series of sexual
adventures and she tries everything i
mean she does all sorts of things right
um
she does a lot of bdsm um she makes
friends with a bunch of other very pure
heightened hearted prostitutes
uh but at one point she sees two men
having sex and she's like
that is too far uh and then at the end
of the book she just has this wonderful
happy ever after so she's like 19
she um she becomes the kept mistress of
a very old sweet man
who then dies leaving her his entire
vast fortune and then she finds the man
she lost her virginity to
and um they get married it's a lovely
story lovely endings where's this from
1740s ish a long time ago yeah you're
saying people in the past
had sex it's hard to believe i think
they might have
news time news time time for the news
have you read any news this week um i
have
i have uh picked up some news from
osmosis
through my various sources yeah okay
cool you sound like a spy master
the main story this week i think you
have heard of i think you can't no one
can
have escaped it this week and that is
gamestop yeah okay
so all right let me some some people on
reddit
were like let's like let's
do a thing that will definitely be made
into a hollywood film in like
three to six years and then they all
grouped together and they you know
upset the wall street men and then aoc
tweeted and was like that's not on wall
street men because
you you reacted to the redditors that's
the story you're working
the story gamestop summed up so what
happened was there is a reddit board
called wall street bets or something
like that and
they decided to stick it to the boomers
um they keep using phrases like boomer
money and they're like right
hedge funds which are companies that
you know manage a lot of money and grow
it for the people that put that money in
and usually
it's wealthier older people with their
money in the hedge fund
they said right we are gonna mess with
these hedge funds
because in the stock market you could do
a thing called short a stock which means
if you think a stock is going to go down
in price
you can take a bet on it yeah
essentially
how it works is say you own a hundred
game gamestop stocks and i think
gamestop is a failing company because it
is
i say hey can i borrow those and
then so i've got your 100 stocks i
sell them and then because i know the
company's dropping
i re-buy them when they're cheaper
to give you back the hundreds you have
but i've made the difference of the
money
right because i sold them and got this
much money and they're giving you them
back
but i paid maybe you know a tenth of
what i paid for so i've made a lot of
money i think roughly that's how
shorting works
what happened was a lot of hedge funds
had shorted gamestop and other companies
and the registers just said let's just
buy a bunch of that stock because buying
the stock pushes the value up because
there's demand
which then means you're in a kind of
like squeeze situation because the hedge
funds
they need to give back the stocks right
they need to but it's not dropped
they have to buy it back at an increased
value and so they lose a lot of money so
hedge a couple of hedge funds went
completely bankrupt they they lost all
their money and
the the controversy that happened was
because the app that people were using
to trade in stocks because if you're a
trader you have special software if
you're just a normal person you have to
get an
robin hood are the main ones um they
suspended trading
in gamestop stocks for the people who
use their app
whereas the wall street people they
could carry on doing it
so that's what aoc was mad about saying
that's not fair just because these
people have gamed you
you can't be like oh that's not fair you
can't play anymore a smaller story
uh in terms of coverage but pretty major
taiwan
right the planes going over so so china
is
china have actually used the word war
this time no they they said if taiwan
if you keep on saying you're an
independent country is an independent
country you keep on saying independent
country
war they didn't say consequences they
said
war that's outrageous yeah still
you know china's big taiwan's were small
yeah but ah i just think people don't
realize
like what a cool legit genuinely real
country taiwan is
i just think it's i was i was there
recently it's oh it's just [ __ ] up
i was getting a new charger from the
apple store in taipei
and as we were getting it we just got
into a conversation and the guy we were
buying
the charger from started being like well
of course it's hard to live in taiwan
because you know that china wants to
crush us
and i was just like really is that
something you think about all the time
and it really is
right it's like something that lurks at
the edge of their consciousness
constantly and how could it not it'd be
terrifying i think
it must be similar to how it would have
felt like you know in america in the 50s
living in the kind of constant fear of
nuclear holocaust
yeah definitely yeah i can't imagine
living through that
something i think that we're bad at
keeping in mind when we think about
history
is that say we're thinking about world
war ii uh we're thinking about what it
was like to be
you know a british civilian during world
war ii
we cannot shake the fact that we know
that germany was defeated from how we
imagine it would be like to live through
world war ii
and i think similarly with you know
living with the threat of nuclear
holocaust during the 50s
we are just like well yep of course but
you would know it wasn't gonna happen
that's not how it felt they would not
know it was not gonna happen
it's like with us in the pandemic so
much of what is stressful is not
knowing what's going to happen and when
we look back on it we won't be able to
really
keep that in mind or all you know
generations to come won't be able to
understand that a big part of the burden
is simply the lack of knowledge that
comes from living through history as
as it happens rather than from imagining
what it would be like to live through
history
you're very clever you're very clever
some politics news
do you know who marjorie taylor green is
sounds like a dressmaker she's not no
she is a
she is a congresswoman for georgia
so george of the state that obviously
just had the two races with
john osoph and raphael warnock reverend
raphael democrats won the democrats one
but they also have a congresswoman who
is absolutely bonkers
she is there's a a push from even some
republican to want to get her out of the
party
more likely off some of the committees
because um
a lot of her old social media has been
kind of turned up
uh where she's calling for the execution
of nancy pelosi
and bernie sanders and all these people
she says
that uh in 2018 the california wildfires
do you know what caused those
oh was it the jews she did say it was
the jews yeah she said it was
um the jews with a space laser
yes i have heard about this uh because i
was talking to some of my jewish friends
and they were like yeah well we
considered
solving sort of world hunger but instead
we decided to cause the fires and i was
like wow i can't believe you're
admitting this this is amazing she's
really mad
yeah and she's very proud of like this
she's like she's like no this is who i
am
she there's footage of her harassing do
you know who david hogg is he's one of
the survivors in the parkland school
shooting
and he obviously pushes for gun control
and she filmed herself before she was in
government i believe
following him in dc shouting at him
being like
why are you trying to take my gun away
why i'm a responsible gun owner i need
it shouting at him
and calls him a coward oh my god can you
imagine following around some like
traumatized a teenage boy whose friends
were murdered
and being like you're a cat what is
wrong with people there's a new vaccine
got a new vaccine that's 66 effective
that seems lower than before
it's lower than before but we've been
spoiled
anything over 50 is good right the tb
vaccine for instance is very low isn't
it
i i wouldn't know i think but
tuberculosis makes you look hot right
um let's not be callous because people
do really get tuberculosis i had to have
three medicals for my green card because
they kept insisting i had to burpee
so i think i have the solution to this i
think the answer to that
what happened uh in england well in
europe you have these um tb vaccines
that everyone has to take
and in america they don't take them and
then when you
get tested for tb in america it looks as
if you have
tb because you have had the vaccine my
main worry was that i had
one medical i then let it expire because
they have to be sent in with your
application within six months and i
we didn't get the application in and so
my second medical is when it showed up
as tb
and in the interim i had been in albania
macedonia and kosovo countries where
there is
quite widespread tuberculosis in areas
right and so i was a bit worried but i
was also like
yeah but i don't have tb well you i mean
you could have
i mean so yeah to be callous for a
second
re tb being glamorous traditionally it
is
very glamorous because so many amazing
artists and poets and painters and
composers have died of tuberculosis and
it makes you kind of thin and your
cheeks go all red and flushed and your
eyes get very bright and the tradition
uh historically the kind of myth around
tb was that you were being kidnapped at
night by the fairies and being forced to
dance in a fairy palace all night
and then when you returned in the day
that's why you were so tired but it also
used to be associated with
sort of sexual corruption so for
instance keats died of tuberculosis i
have a lot of tuberculosis fight facts
by the way so keith started tuberculosis
and um he actually all of it like pretty
much everyone in his family died of
tuberculosis
but he never called it tuberculosis or
consumption because it was associated
with this kind of sexual iniquity
and so instead he was just like oh my my
brother is very you know
coughing sick so keats keeps his
whole family died of tuberculosis and
heat's got tuberculosis and
he was sent to rome i know you want to
move on but sit down
um and he was sent to rome and he had
this absolutely
insane doctor in rome who um was like
look
a i don't think you're sick i think
you're just thinking too hard try not to
think
keith was like okay i'll try not to this
is what doctors thought was wrong with
women whenever they were sick they were
like oh
your womb has crept up to your brain
well that is in fairness
always my problem uh so keats tries very
hard not to think he's 25 poor keats
and uh that doesn't work he still has
tuberculosis
so then the doctor is like look we're
gonna starve it out
and so keats gets put on this diet where
he's allowed
one piece of toast and two anchovies
a day and then he just died of
starvation
i've heard a rumor that anchovies in the
past were actually massive and that's
essentially the same as having two whole
trout as well so i think he's really
blown this out of all proportions
uh that's only one of my many
tuberculosis stories but
i will we'll save them for later
episodes we'll have a little
tb time section uh tb
continued hey that's it no
it's worth more though hey
there's a new vaccine which is a
one-dose vaccine
and it can be kept at fridge
temperatures who's good who made it so
it's made by a belgian company called
janssen who i think are related to
johnson and johnson hence janssen
and yeah janssen they they are i think
that's why um that's not that's not a
[ __ ] joke that's a fact that sounded
like a [ __ ] joke
the main vaccine news this week though
is uh that
the eu it's very very angry
with astrazeneca what was that
astrazeneca made one of the vaccines one
of the big successful ones that came up
we had pfizer and astrozenyx so you told
me a little bit about this new story
it's something to do with
uh basically because of brexit
in part indirectly britain is ending up
with vaccines and
europe isn't kind of yeah so you the eu
bought vaccines for all its nations
as a group it was like look we're going
to get 300 million vaccines because
there's this many million people in the
eu
but they were slower than britain to get
vaccines so they said astrazeneca
and britain have vaccines from other
companies but also astrazeneca were like
we'll give you a hundred million and the
eu were like we want
300 million and they're like yeah sure
we'll give you it and then
the eu's like where our vaccines are
like oh we didn't say when we'd give you
it we've got some delays at our plants
so we can only give you this much so
they're getting quite a lot fewer
vaccine doses than they thought they
would
and the eu commission kicked off like
real kicked off
because you know the citizens want
vaccines
and they said right we're not
exporting any more of our vaccines to
other countries this is just going to be
for us
and any vaccines made in the uk by that
company you've got to give them to us
now
no see the uk is like uh no we don't um
astrazeneca have now said
look we can make some more vaccines for
you and maybe australia is a beautiful
name
it is isn't it astrazeneca win this is
my daughter astrazeneca
hi i'm astrazeneca hi welcome to my
unboxing video but hopefully everyone
gets their vaccines right i'm not saying
without a brexit so i could all die yeah
darling you are assuming that everyone
who voted brexit is working class
we voted brexit so they can all die yes
that's better that's very true
european news sad sad news in poland
poland's banning abortions are they no
more abortion poland
um that sort of surpri what religion is
poland christian yeah but what i mean
yeah but are they like orthodox are they
chris are they sure this isn't a news
story i read much into i just saw the
headline it was like
big protest in poland because is
abortion
is abortion legal in russia do you know
oh
i'm not sure i don't know i have to
check with my russian friend sergey
hello it's me sergey ah chris yes
abortion
i don't know you can get pushed maybe no
position you look up on your phone
look up on my phone on your phone hey
phone fun fun
abortion in russia is legal as an
elective procedure up to the 12th week
of pregnancy
that's that's pretty early i think we
have we have 20
20 weeks over here yeah i think maybe 20
times yeah do you know the company
general motors
they make cars they do make cars they're
a very huge car manufacturer
they have said by 2035 all their cars
will be
electric well done that was very
patronizing
electric cars being made by a huge
manufacturer hopefully we'll make them
cheaper because the problem with
electric cars
are still pretty expensive they're so
quiet they're so quiet which is uh my
favorite joke in the sellout
about how drive-by shootings have gone
deadlier ever since the prius became a
thing because now
you can't hear the car that will shoot
you just you see a prayer is pulling up
and suddenly everyone jumps behind the
wall like we're going to get shot
if you haven't read the sell out read
the sell out unless you listen to alice
in which case she's going to tell you
to not read this i wasn't so keen on it
but it won the man booker and
the man booker and i do not tend to get
along yes which is a prize
yes the man booker makes it sound like
someone who organizes strippers for a
hindu
um bachelorette party for our american
cousins we've had the main news stories
this week now time for
breaking news which is a news story that
happened today
so there's no way you've heard about
this i'm going to see if you can guess
it though okay
i want to see if you can guess this the
new story involves
captain sir tom moore
he's the man who made lots of money by
walking with his walker
yes now we should clarify by made lots
of money i don't mean in a jeff bezos or
zuckerberg he raised lots of money yeah
so at the start of the pandemic
he said he wanted to raise money for the
nhs the british health service
by doing a hundred laps of his garden
which would be 25 meters so
2500 meters this man is 99 years old at
this point he's very very
old right for in the war which war
world war ii i imagine otherwise i don't
know
all the world war veterans are dead um
you made sure of that
um so he wanted to raise a thousand
pounds
now what happened was it went crazy
viral and one and a half million people
donated and he ended up raising almost
33
million pounds for the national health
service which you know an amazing thing
but also
oi tories fund the health service
properly
right so we stop after raising money for
it right right
um so the new story involves him he's
100 years old now um what's in the new
story is what was the breaking news it
better not be that he's dead he's not
died
he has a girlfriend he has a girlfriend
he found love he and the queen have been
writing each other letters and they're
going to publish them in a book coming
out
january 2020 these are all much nicer
than the actual news which is he's in
hospital with coronavirus oh
no i know it's very sad
it's very sad he had pneumonia now he's
not in intensive care
and the reason i put this in is just you
know because i think
maybe a lot of people outside of the uk
don't know who he is
and i think it was a very amazing story
a nice story of the start of pandemic
right um and we we send our best wishes
because absolutely
yeah hope he's all right once he
recovers i reckon he can get back out in
that garden raise another 33 million
to pay his medical bill because you know
um he won't have to have a huge medical
bill because of the nhs
that's true but we you know we so we we
wish
captain sir tomorrow captain colonel sir
tom moore they gave him an honorary
colonel-ness
colonel hood colonel they coloneled him
um so yeah captain colonel sir tom moore
uh
may you get well soon we have a new
segment
uh a new segment this week called fake
news
which is not what it sounds like it is
the segment where alice tells me
about a news story that she thought was
a news story and then realized was not
actually a new story i
i called to chris in a panic earlier
today no yesterday because
i um i saw on instagram which is
just an awful place that britain was
returning
the elgin marbles to greece and i was
like chris
chris is is britain returning the elgin
marbles to greece
and chris was like i don't think so and
i was like ah well it says so here on
this
tumblr instagram i follow which just
posts like tumblr memes so i think
you'll find it has
happened uh and we googled it and it has
not happened and
it's never going to happen it might
happen it might happen so so chris and i
both had a
chat about this because we feel the same
way which is
yeah they should get them back but also
they're mine and they're really pretty
nice to go to london and stand in the
room and look we built
a wing of the british museum for them
now obviously
it is insane that britain has them it
makes no sense i was saying this to
chris
even in the early 19th century like lord
byron
was like what is going on we haven't
there's no reason we should have these
this is crazy and yet here we are yeah i
mean he was
he was the voice of reason despite the
fact he was a massive pedophile
all right right settle down i think
people okay
most people if you think of lord byron
they're like oh yeah he was mad
bad and dangerous to know he had lots
and lots of lovers and he wrote poetry
right that's what people think about him
he's a romantic poet he's one of the six
romantic poets
uh he
i feel like up in that list of facts
people generally know about lord byron
you should know about the fact that he
was
very much into children one time he was
in greece
and he tried to buy an 11 year old girl
off some greek peasants for 500 pounds
and
they said we'll only sell her to you if
you argue that the marble should be
returned to us
uh they refused um later in his life so
he died when he was 36 whilst fighting
in it for greek independence he felt
madly in love with this um 14 year old
boy who
just was not into him and the 14 year
old boy led him on a merry chase and
uh made byron just buy him so much stuff
and byron just bought him more and more
stuff like hoping that this
gift he bought this 14 year old boy
would be the thing that made the 14 year
boy fall in love with him and
it didn't the fortuner boy thought he
was just like this weird old pervert
which you know he was i could go on
about byron
in more depth i mean there's five other
romantic poets that you're going to need
to tell us about that the fact is
college was pretty interesting as well
but let's
yeah so we've got guys keep stay tuned
for more romantic poets and more tb
facts we're now at the part of the show
where you get to tell us
something that you've learned this week
not from the news but from
your wide-ranging reading habits uh i
know you've been reading quite a few
things this week so
which one you want to tell us about well
i just finished dante's inferno
the context of dante's life is that um
he was in love with a beautiful woman
called beatrice who then died
uh before he could marry her i don't
think she was going to marry him anyway
but point is she died
and then he was exiled from florence and
he wrote this
um you know epic series of poems a
divine comedy
uh which is broken up into the inferno
purgatorio and paradisa so the premise
is
beatrice the woman he was in love with
who died is in heaven watching dante and
she's like ah he's running his life into
the ground
so she sends virgil to go and guide
dante through uh heaven purgatory and
hell
virgil the greek poet he's uh roman
reigns
he wrote the init uh he is the greatest
roman poet believes the medieval
um people what is he actually uh i
haven't read
virgil but i do know it's important to
read i'm planning to because um
like it's one of these things where
people don't really read virgil very
much anymore
but so much of our literature span out
from virgil
it reminds me a bit of milton right no
one really reads milton anymore but
um if you do go and read paradise lost
you're like oh actually a lot of stuff
now makes sense to me because i can see
that it had its roots
kind of like if you only read fantasy
novels now but you never read
lord of the rings like you should read
the rings anyway uh so you shouldn't
read all the rings absolutely load of
[ __ ] i
loved it when he was reading lord of the
rings in his little group
of writers they always to hang out
together called the inklings um
and he one of the writers fell asleep
woke up
tolkien was still reading and the guy
said not another [ __ ] elf
that's how i feel about lord of the
rings yeah yeah you're not you're not a
fan not a true fan
i love a lot of the rings anyway so what
i there's quite a lot to say about
dante's inferno and i'm just gonna focus
on the inferno but
uh let's start with how ballsy it is
to be like i'm going to write my
masterpiece
in which my favorite author hangs out
with me
and spends the entire poem telling me
how great i
am so it's lots and lots of virgil being
like dante
by the way you are so talented and dante
being like thanks
are you sure and virgil been like yeah
you really are
um which is like if i were to have a
poem that i wrote about
milton just telling me i'm a genius it's
it's
i think funny um and he does kind of a
lot of just i think fairly
ballsy things like that like um he
populates hell with just people he
doesn't like
um which i mean sure great good idea
but he also does some of these people
alive when he published it
yes there are some people who are alive
in hell because and he's like he comes
in he runs across someone and he's like
hang on how are you in hell you're alive
and that person's like well sometimes
our soul dies before our body and then
our body gets taken over by a demon
so my soul is here in hell but my body
is still up there doing bad stuff
so i think the moment when dante does
like the
biggest dick move he's in the gay
section of hell
where they keep all the sodomites and he
runs into someone he knows
um and he says are you here sir brunetto
and brunetto uh brunetto latini
lettini was uh dante's teacher
and this is such a dick move on dante's
part because
a he's outing brunetto right
there's very little evidence other than
dante that brunetto
was gay b within the poem
dante is all like oh my god i'm so sorry
like that's so
[ __ ] i'm you know what bad luck that
you're in here wow it's terrible
but if you back out it's like no dante
you you put him here
you made sure that brunetto latini's
most famous thing for all eternity is
that he's in
the seventh circle of hell in the
section for sodomites that was you dante
so however much you're being like oh wow
i really respect and admire you
you're still screwing over his legacy i
just think it was a real big move
there's a section of the river styx um
which is just you know it's it's the
river from the greek underworld
and it's really murky and muddy and
gross and kind of filled with sewage and
refuge uh refuse and
um in this river uh you have two groups
of people being punished you have
the angry and the angry are just
fighting each other sort of biting each
other's ears off
and the sullen so the river is
boiling it looks like it's bubbling but
actually it's not boiling what's going
on is the sullen
are just permanently drowning in this
river the sudden the depressed the
people who did not
you know admire life around them uh just
kind of
lie in this river of filth breathing out
their discontent
and bubbling up the water do you want to
guess
how prophet muhammed is doing um i would
hope he is respectfully
talked about and not illustrated and
peace be upon him
he's not doing so well according to
dante he
um he is i think he's in the eighth
circle of hell
uh because he sews religious discord and
he if you want to join my religious
discord then the link will be below
and he is um i think he his sort of
stomach is cut open his entrails are
just falling out but interestingly
um his son-in-law ali is also there
uh which is interesting because so
muhammad is there because he served
religious discord he distracted people
from christianity
but ali is there ali is there because he
sowed religious discord within islam
claims dante
by creating the sunni and shia yeah
rift so interesting it's the end of the
show which means it's time for
me to do a rippety wrap and you to
listen but you get to make the
suggestions uh based on things we've
spoken about this
week so what would you like a rap about
my dear
marjorie taylor green biden's feelings
when twitter said he couldn't keep all
of trump's followers
please can china leave taiwan alone yeah
the river sticks
in dante's inferno where the angry and
the sullen hang out
and tuberculosis
tuberculosis yeah cool okay here we go a
little freestyle
name so posh that you might mistake her
not for congress woman but a dressmaker
the weirdest wack job that you've ever
seen calling that last
marjorie taylor green it's obscene all
the conspiracies that she spreads online
with such frequency
execute nancy kill aoc chase down david
hogg in dc
now marjorie you a bad lass i hope you
get
kicked off on your fat ass i don't know
what her size is maybe she's slim
let me work it out getting into that gym
like an
eight-year-old president near soon biden
on twitter
we can just assume that he was so sad he
was like no
all of my followers had to go starting
from
oh the bottom line drake twitter ceo
jack dorsey takes every single follower
but joe you know
all the people don't like you any would
you want all of trump's fans getting on
your feed
every time you press tweet issuing a
screed against you
the real defender rd he would be like
oh joe you're too stuttery and too
sleepy
not nice feeling kind of sad yes rivers
of ice in the ninth circle but i take it
up and lift
feeling kind of sullen so i'm in the
river sticks stick me at the bottom
please unhand me i'm just so depressed
why are you all so angry
flowing up here biting off each other's
ears but the people at the bottom be
bereft of
any cheer just bubbling looking like
it's boil
ooh if you've got war then there's
spoils that's the type of treasure
that's the type of loot but if you
taiwanese hands up
don't shoot please chinese people don't
come much into our island
we're just independent sovereign
understand
but the chinese people don't agree
president xi
jinping i'm gonna come and get
all the taipei i hope there's no war for
any day that's ever happening what's the
last we want to do
yeah i got it from you that's the tb
getting all tuberculosis people in the
past know all the keats bald the poets
catching his whole family were corrupted
affected
he would never say never instruct the
doctor to say
is tb tuberculosis just say he'd be hurt
for sure in his lungs
it's something because it's done with
the sex that's what you explained to me
and what's next
i went to the doctor for my medical call
i said yeah i've traveled
all around the world have you been to
albania yes then you've got it
oh no it's another 150 bucks i had to
drop it i had to get an x-ray which
cost money to prove i didn't have it a
chest x-ray that's they prove it and
they were like oh you don't have it
that is the end of the show if you would
like to hear more amazing
facts about poetry then of course you
can follow my lovely wife at
let them eat books on instagram so to
let them eat books but with underscores
instead of spaces and i review books and
do film reviews etc
yeah um just get at her with that
casablanca hey please don't please don't
please be nice to her and uh me chris
turn a comedy on instagram if you're
watching on youtube then you can also
listen to these on apple podcasts and
through spotify
if you're listening then you can also
watch them on youtube new episodes every
monday thank you for listening and uh
from me chris turner and from her alice
win goodbye